our team protecting the bay at all cost
there's nothing you see me people that's
a very watery [ __ ]
training begins at oh six hundred but
seeing oh six hundred that's not a real
time and we all know it well such a dick
we got a murder on our Beach someone's
covering it up we're lifeguard
now cops I don't know what it means they
watch on like giant air the gorillas
rigid or just what is it like you think
we do here so we were lifeguards I mean
this what happened to that last creeply
recruit one to your daughter
you just ask my boobs I not here here
[Music]
oh just
welcome to Baywatch just here for the
qualifiers one direction when is this
late guard hazy
oh you stick you turned the canals into
the X game we were in lifeguard pursuit
okay except there's no such thing as
lifeguard pursuit night night mission
welcome to Baywatch
I came to see Elise of the elite for the
heart soul of this very Beach come on
feet make my pecs a little bigger and
don't come around my front pump we got
it huge dick
big dick the little murmur you're for
qualified I don't have to try out and
that Brody comes to gold medal hey Brody
yes we need its message my boobs right
not here here if you're gonna be on this
team One Direction very big that's why
I'm fast drugs murder a dead body on our
Beach and it all started once she's
recovered some people are up to no good
we're gonna have to do what they watch
the best your lifeguard not to leave
[Music]
why does he put six assignments for mom
the reason I believe in God we gotta
call their cover where the hell is Brody
I don't wanna make up
why I'm wearing makeup a little much I
look legit ha everybody almost yet even
born ain't got [ __ ] Oh mr. go why ever
reason the more got to get some hard
evidence somewhat coming forward you
know shall we hide here all radiators
are empty what you big natural how much
it's just a little dead man's back the
chronic live with that and we stopped
you too baby bit about
you
you